no I'm fine thank you  oh it wasn't a question you need help  because your bag is leaking Paulo thanks  you Paulo it's my horse  he named your horse after a Greek god I  figured he could use the inspiration but  turns out it just gave him a big head I  think he thinks he's better than me  you're sure I can't give you him thank  you oh you knew my name's Gabriel oh  I've heard about you yeah belly and wash  I grew up right down the road  my sister and I run the orphanage we  have an orphanage had some catching up  to do  yes it seemed so well thank you for  feeding my horse  should he be on the boardwalk like I  said he's got a big head if you'll  excuse me  [Music]